foreign
97 of all startups
fail and only two and a half percent of
VC fund Adventures will become a unicorn
reached a billion dollar valuation mark
statistically speaking
only one person in our classroom at
Stanford MBA program will become and
found a unicorn in their lifetime
well it can become you
or you
are you or me
as it happens I've already been a
unicorn
the musical kind
for 16 years I chased Perfection on the
piano I won International music
competitions I studied that the most
prestigious conservatories and I gained
Fame in my home country Sweden
there is nothing in the piano repertoire
that I cannot master
now my days as a concert pianist are in
the past and today I'm chasing that
entrepreneurial unicorn in the present
now as I have completed my transition
from music to business
and help but notice important parallels
between the two
it takes a Grand Vision incredible hard
work and constant improvisation to build
a unicorn whether the musical or
business kind
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
La Campanella is known for its
captivating Melody and a thundering
climax it's a four minute piece that
only the most proficient players can
master
I learned La Campanella age 14 when I
devised the formula that would enable me
to challenge the most difficult pieces
out there I have perfected this formula
over the years and it has helped me stay
on top of my game ever since
now to conquer La Campanella I
envisioned a grand vision of how it
would look
how it would sound
but
did I go from this
[Music]
do this
for inspiration I would listen to the
recordings on my all-time favorite
pianists over and over and over again
and I would picture myself playing the
most wonderful rendition of this piece
next what did it take to make my vision
a
very detailed plan of action
being able to play thousands of notes in
a minute coordinate the two hands and
memorize all the music we take careful
thinking of how we would learn each of
these things and
so I said Milestones one for instance
could I expect to conquer this piece in
two three
four months
I also divided this piece into
bite-sized passages
I'm focused on nailing every single
passage one day one at a time
[Music]
dividing the workload into concrete
actionable steps made learning La
Campanella so much more manageable and
less daunting
and after a while I was ready to put
together all of these passages into one
cohesive interpretation bringing me that
much closer to my grandfather
[Music]
similarly some of the best entrepreneurs
out there start our journey with a grand
vision of how our future Venture will
look like what's the impact we want to
have how will we change lives
organizations the world
co-founder of the Swedish unicorn clarna
started his vision it started his
journey with a Crystal Clear Vision of
how his Innovative by now pay later
business model would disrupt the
old-fashioned Retail Finance industry
Rome wasn't built in a day and neither
is a company like Florida built on a
solid foundation
Sebastian's Grand Vision inspired by his
hero Richard Branson of the Virgin group
enabled him to hire key employees who
shared his values ignore the multiple
Skeptics telling him this idea would
never work and attend hundreds of
investor meetings often taking them for
an answer
but of course just having a grand vision
isn't enough
you need to put in the hours
for instance as I was learning La
Campanella I went through every single
note Rhythm and Tempo in the score and I
internalized it
I didn't shy away from putting it 12
hour days for days on end rehearsing
every single note to perfection
[Music]
and so and on at the expense of my
fingers and arms
sacrificing countless evenings and
weekends
but by the time I was rated to perform
for an audience I knew this piece inside
out in a way that I could literally play
it with my eyes closed
[Music]
there are no shortcuts when learning a
piece and neither are those when
building a successful company
during the first year of starting
doordash a unicorn and today the largest
online food delivery company in the
world full-time students Tony zoo and
his co-founders worked Around the Clock
interviewing hundreds of business owners
and delivering the first 200 customer
orders door-to-door by themselves
gaining first-hand knowledge of what
worked and what didn't
putting in those extra hours and being
Incredibly Close to every single product
detail enable Tony to map out all of the
consumer pain points and identify his
product Market fit had Tony not done
this doordash as we know it might not
have been
born just imagine not being able to get
that late night restaurant delivery to
your house
but of course just having a grand vision
and working incredibly hard isn't enough
either you can't brute force a learning
process
improvisation is needed to unlock
creativity and uncover things that we
didn't know we were capable of
for instance there were so many times
when I was as I was learning La
Campanella I just get stuck in a passage
perhaps my fingers just wouldn't work at
the desired speed
[Music]
or maybe I was simple out of ideas
I didn't know how to proceed but I
needed to find a way to make it work
so I'd let my fingers loose
or play around experimenting
I'd also consult with other pianists on
what had worked for them all in the
spirit of unlocking some sort of new
insight
and surprisingly it worked
every single time
equally we entrepreneurs must
consistently think outside of the box to
keep our businesses alive and growing at
a fast pace
co-founder and CEO of Spotify
takes pride in crediting his curiosity
for his success
when Daniel first set out to build
Spotify music piracy was rampant and no
one has figured out a way how to build a
business model that worked for music
streamers artists and record labels
Daniel and his co-founder Martin would
get together for daily brainstorming
sessions the willingness to constantly
challenge their assumptions and balance
seemingly ridiculous ideas off of each
other led to them uncovering
groundbreaking business models such as
Spotify premium
such improvisational attitude has made
Spotify the global leading music
streaming business for the past 15 years
so there you are the next time you're
contemplating that billion dollar idea
just remember
Grand Vision incredible hard work and
improvisation
and you might just have your unicorn a
long lasting success that few others can
only dream of
just think like a
[Music]
like
[Applause]
[Music]